in the wake of the Paris event a lot of
people were really paranoid and mad
because refugees were coming in Canada
so we knit against fear and again
against racism it just gives a way for
normal people to express that they're
not against people coming in when
there's a war an emergency Thursday
nights we have knit nights and this week
we're actually hosting an event for the
25,000 tooks it's a great way to talk to
children about it and have them filled
involved and a way for them to give back
to the people who are coming to join us
in our country
in Quebec we give tips to every newborn
our almost every newborn because it's
cold so I thought it was like a very
symbolic and very strong idea to knit
those beanies for the refugees because
they were starting a new life with us